oh I love Scotch eggs oh they're so
yummy yeah use your giant hands to rip
it but it's delicious it smells like a
donut oh it's definitely not a donut
what does it go it's not gonna like
squirt up no no because I'm not cool
with it I'm just letting you know I got
my limits no sweating if it squirts on
me we're done it's boiled okay
I used to eat these like a psychopath
hmm
oh is that the first time you've had one
yeah it's just pretty much sausage meat
bread crumbs and this is like a great
breakfast thing yeah like you know that
warm you could eat that on a go no mess
no fuss to me for more
exotic taste I'm gonna go with Scotch
egg too come on I'm not sure exotic
taste and Scotch egg have ever been used
in the same sentence for me it's very
exotic just uh the textures take just
take it this is our one thing that we
can be called exotic for a second